the run-up to christmas has been clouded
by worries over omicron but now the uk
health security agency says there are
reasons for cautious optimism its
analysis has confirmed the variant
causes milder symptoms than delta
this is a sign that in as an individual
your risk of severe disease is
potentially reduced and your risk of
hospitalization is reduced however
we've got very high amounts of infection
circulating and so the more infections
that we have circulating in our
population the more people that will get
admitted to hospital and put hospitals
under pressure
the analysis by the uk health security
agency shows people infected with
omicron are 30 to 45 percent less likely
than those with delta to go to a e and
they're 50 to 70 percent less likely to
need to be admitted
there are a couple of caveats though the
number crunching was on just 132
hospitalized omicron cases and there
were very few over the age of 60 the
group most at risk of serious disease
but even a much milder virus could still
overwhelm the nhs take a look at this
scientists at the university of warwick
have modeled what could happen if
omicron severity was just 20
of deltas they found plan b won't be
enough to reduce the pressure on
hospitals their central estimate is that
there will be a peak of just under 5 000
admissions a day in england that's even
higher than the peak of almost 4 600
last january there's a lot of
uncertainty though as you can see from
all that shading
bringing in a circuit breaker that lasts
until mid-january with the old step two
restrictions from the spring so no
indoor mixing and the rule of six
outdoors is likely to reduce the peak to
around 3 000 admissions a day but only
if they had started earlier this week
that line in blue or if they kick in on
boxing day the line in orange wait to
bring them on until january the other
two lines and they'll be too late to
make a difference but ministers are
holding out we're not planning any
further announcements uh this week uh
you know i want people to uh to despite
the the caution that we're all taking
the sensible caution you know people
should enjoy their christmases with
their families and friends of course
remain cautious and we will keep the
situation under review
even if the variant isn't the threat
that many had feared based on its
mutations scientists warn we may not be
so fortunate next time viruses are not
really
intending to damage their host they just
want to replicate and transmit and we
now see there's a paradigm or a
mechanism for the virus to fulfill all
of its evolutionary needs uh without
harming us to this to a similar degree
but of course the next variant that
arises may not may not do this it may be
completely different and therefore the
strategies for vaccination infection
control really needs to be considered
carefully so today
the uk health security agency also found
the effect of the booster is already
beginning to wane with protection
against symptomatic disease dropping by
15 to 25
10 weeks after having the jab it says
protection against serious disease is
likely to hold up for longer and there
are no signs yet that the uk needs to
follow israel in giving people a fourth
dose
thomas more sky news